all right guys
bang bang i've got michael here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
thank you for having me absolutely let's
jump right into your background what did
you do before uh you started the company
so uh my background is mostly in
alternative investments and specialty
finance
but actually when i first started out i
really thought i wanted to
learn about the real estate market and
be a developer that was like the most
exciting thing for me
and i remember talking to my dad about
it when i was getting ready to start
college
and i said you know like if i want to
get into real estate what should i do
he's like we got to start at the bottom
clean toilets
and i'm like okay that's uh can i do
like one step
above that and so uh i started out doing
125 cold calls a day
um i had this sick work ethic at a young
age
a different time i'll tell you about uh
my middle school and high school side
hustles
but um what were they now tell us right
now what were they all right
so uh i'll give you the the middle
school side hustle was great
so um they we had i was in an all-volley
school
on long island and uh in eighth grade
they decided to upgrade the lockers and
uh the way it worked was you had to pay
like 125 bucks for a locker
but the locker would stay in your family
so for all the brothers you had in the
school now i had no brothers in the
school and it's like december time in
eighth grade and i'm like
like how am i going to pull this off you
know how it is like you want to be the
cool kid with the locker
so another friend of mine we we decided
we're going to convince our parents
to start a business with us so we bought
about six or seven lockers
and then we went to like the variety
store we got locker dividers went to
costco
we put in like those huge family bags of
rolos and mints
and we essentially sublet space in the
lockers
to people who couldn't pay the 125 bucks
six became ten once that happened the
school couldn't sell any other lockers
so we actually got suspended for
subdividing real estate in school
and taking the revenue away which is
kind of an awesome side hustle
and uh so i did a couple of things like
that you know ordered bagels and
people didn't want the school food and
we used to get uh one day credit terms
from the local bagel store
and get 100 bagels and so um the older
kids
started school an hour before the
younger kids stopped fifth grade my next
door neighbor was like on the younger
bus
it was the same bus driver doing the
route twice so i made a deal with him
and i give him a bialy and cream cheese
every day if you pick me up on the last
stop of the second round
and i went around the corner of the
bagel store my parents thought i went to
school earlier and then i would come
with my hundred bagels and resell them
to
everybody in school so i had this like
sick work ethic
even as a young kid i credit that to my
dad but anyway i um
i would get into the office around seven
o'clock 7 30 i would catch up on emails
bust out 125 calls a day leave the
office by 5
40 run five bucks away to school that
was 5 50 to 10 30 twice a week
come back 10 30 at night catch up on my
emails do my school work and repeat the
next day
and so um it was a tough time it was a
grueling time
you don't see success for a number of
months there and uh but i think it was
an amazing experience to tell you
resilience it taught you about rejection
and so i started there found my way into
um into the hedge fund world into
private capital markets
originally was doing pretty simple stuff
like receivable finance purchase order
funding
and what i realized early on is that uh
so a mentor once told me
riches are made in niches and he's like
you gotta identify something for
yourself it's different than everybody
else is doing
and what i learned pretty early on was
that there's something called perceived
risk versus actual risk
and so things that are at times more
complicated
um people will deem as higher risk and
ultimately you get to get paid a lot
more for those opportunities and my
first
foray into that world was in the legal
finance world so in 2009 there was
really very limited players in that
space
and what i realized was that like any
other asset
contingency law firms that let's say sue
pharmaceutical companies or antitrust
cases or class actions
had an asset that wasn't clearly defined
and so there's a level of risk around
that ambiguity but if you can get a big
enough and a diversified enough
portfolio
then it's a really interesting strategy
that is no correlation to broader
markets
and there really wasn't competitive
there were four people in the world that
i knew doing it at that time
and so that was my first i had some
other fun i did uh i did a lending
strategy around the nba lockout if you
remember that back in the day
and so we were lending players during
the lockout against the guaranteed
portions of their contract
and so for me what i learned early on is
if i could roll up my sleeves work a
little bit harder than the guy next to
me get a little bit luckier than the guy
next to me
and try and do something different that
if you uh if you put the work in and you
put the effort in
then that's really a path for success
and in 2013 i started my own fund with
another partner
and we focused on legal finance and
other asymptotic opportunities
but what was happening was really
interesting as i got more successful
two things happen so one is you know
high net worth investors
who would hear by word of mouth and
other people that hey i heard you did a
great deal i heard my friend was in this
deal
you know can i come into the next one i
can give you 500 million 2 million 250
whatever
and that flow of traffic was increasing
significantly
but from an administrative perspective
it became really difficult
to manage that and at the same time my
business was growing the size of the
investments that i was looking to make
was much larger
and so i needed to really get some
serious capital without spending 50
percent of my time
doing dinners and lunches and meetings
etc and so
the first foray into institutional world
i was able to secure with my partner's
108 million dollar investment it took us
almost nine months and we got retraded
twice
and here you are more successful than
you've ever been before with a track
record with everything else you got the
whole world
knocking down your door on the retail
side and
basically you just got screwed twice and
you don't have a choice because
you know you have all these deals lined
up to close this 108 million bucks and
you got to take it etc
and so i went to a mentor of mine and i
said i don't understand like how this is
and he pats me on the back he was about
80 at the time and he goes welcome to
the big boys
you're going to spend 40 to 50 of your
time raising capital and to me that was
super frustrating because that's not the
part of the role that i ever enjoyed
what i enjoyed was identifying the
strategies the asset classes finding
alpha working through
helping people grow businesses like
that's where i personally
got a lot of excitement and a lot of
sort of stimulation and that's where my
energy was really focused it wasn't
focused on on the raising capital
on the other side of the equation you
have all these people
that don't have access to these
investments that were literally without
a tremendous amount of work ready to say
hey let me in let me in
and as i would talk to my friends at the
time who were coming out of law school
and dental and this and that and the
other
and i said hey guys so you know you're
starting to make real money where are
you investing
and it was all like three percent four
percent five percent not interesting
stuff not stuff that's going to help
them get ahead there's no
sort of foreseeable future to financial
independence and i would say
well you know you're caught and i'm
caught in my bubble at the time like why
aren't you investing in the types of
stuff
that i do with other players etc and
they're like well we can't access them
like nobody wants to take 20 50 100 000.
and so for me you know i realized that
the system was very much broken
in how investors can access product and
how managers can distribute product
and so where the price is ultimately
paid
is in lower yield to investors and in
lower performance fees
for managers because there's a huge fee
compression in the model
and so for me it was a general
frustration um and that's sort of
a bit about my background and what i was
doing and how i embarked on uh
knowing that there's got to be a better
way to embark on this journey
what's the worst story you have on the
fundraising trail i feel like every
manager
has that one story that they're just
like you'll never believe what happened
what's yours
i would actually say my worst story most
dramatic story
was when i was still in the real estate
space which is really the impetus for
why i left
so um i was working on a 13 property
portfolio refinance i even remember the
guy's name
based out of collierville tennessee okay
don't say his name but go ahead
say his name but to tell you there's a
jewish kid from new york showing up in
colorado tennessee like that's an
experience in and of itself
all right and so i'm spending a
tremendous amount of time
we're with one of the major investment
banks who have a term sheet out
committed capital we're supposed to be
closing in a couple of weeks
we're going through the diligence we get
five days away from closing everything
is done commitment letter is out
deposit is in i got a very simple email
real estate lending is shut down
indefinitely
2008 i write back wtf with a bunch of
exclamation points and question marks
he writes back same tried getting him on
the phone for a day nothing
finally calls him back he goes it is
what it is we don't know where the world
is going we're not lending
and so imagine spending six months on a
13 property portfolio refi
with an 80 something year old guy and
you're already counting your commission
right i'm young at that time that's a
point in commission it's a big deal
and uh gone poof five days before
closing
so i'd say that was probably my biggest
um my biggest most traumatic moment
which also was part of the reason i left
because it made me realize
i had no control over my destiny on the
one hand i had to call and identify and
get referred and sort of find
clients and on the other hand i didn't
even control
whether or not i could do a deal and so
the reason to go into the fund world was
hey at least there's a pot of capital
or at least there's access to capital
that if you can find the right
opportunity and you do the hard work and
you get to the finish line you have
control over your destiny
and so that was my most traumatic
experience or let down i would say in
fundraising and it stuck with me
ever since and how i think about capital
formation how i think about maintaining
diversity of capital
um it's always been sort of running
through my blood
absolutely and talk a little bit about
yield street in terms of what exactly
was the original impetus for
starting the business and kind of how
did you think about uh what you guys
were going to actually go build from a
product standpoint
yeah so a lot of it has to do with what
we just spoke about sort of recognizing
how inefficient the market was both for
asset managers
and for retail looking to access capital
there's another really
sort of um emotional or interesting
story
that very much uh drives a lot of
decision making that i've had over my
career
which sort of lingered for a long time i
didn't exactly know how to deal with it
or how to fix it
and so i think back to um december time
2008
i come home for hanukkah dinner
with the family and um my dad's sitting
at the kitchen table manila envelope
white in the face which is not very
likely for my dad to give you a sense of
who he is
pretty resilient fellow childhood a
child of holocaust survivors grew up in
vienna austria shipped out at age 12 to
go to school
sort of a very very different different
world grew up completely broke
built a successful business for himself
at least you know had what he can sort
of living the american dream
at you know at his level and um big
saver
very european in that sense and sort of
pushed all his extra savings into
into charles schwab we always had what
we need growing up weren't rich
but we're good and um that's just who he
is and so this white face is just very
uncharacteristic i thought maybe it was
like a health issue
and so i'm prodding him to like you know
tell me what's what's up and he's not
he's not gonna give
um tough guy and he goes he goes to the
bathroom or goes somewhere and i you
know like a disrespectful son sneak into
the envelope to see what's going on
and i see his portfolios down about 50
and uh ultimately he sells the remainder
of the portfolio in a panic really not
understanding
where the market's going to go and i
remember in such a juvenile way
saying like why would you put all your
money in schwapp like why aren't you
invested in a bunch of stuff and he
wrote he said back to me like well
that's what people do
like we save we put in schwab and we
expect to retire and like everything's
going to be great
and so for me at first i honestly
thought it was the dumbest answer ever
because i was too young to appreciate it
but looking back
over the following few years the first
thing was like i was petrified of ever
having to have that experience
the second was i was determined whatever
it took to be diversified in what my
investment approach and what my income
approach would be
and i went on that journey right and so
the real estate idea was hey i could
always have multiple deals in the fire
and the fund idea is obvious we're
always investing in different strategies
asset classes etc
um but the part that never that i was
never able to figure out how to fix
which came up again as i was building my
fund was how do we get
people to have financial independence
why is it
that you got 90 of the population
working
some of the people on the low side of
the economic totem pole are working
harder than the people on the high side
right like i don't think hard work is
the terminating factor per se
but they have no way to get ahead so if
you think about the mission or the goal
of achieving financial independence in
its simplest terms it's
how do i get comfortable that i can pay
every bill i have without ever having to
worry like that's my
sort of view and obviously for everybody
that's a different level
but that's what we want to achieve you
want to wake up in the morning you got a
bill you click auto pay
and you're good to go and there really
isn't a path to get ahead and so i was
always inspired by the idea
of why is it always the big institutions
getting that access but to be candid i
never really
had a moment of clarity where i was able
to figure out
how can i be a part of that movement and
so i was on my merry way doing my thing
with the fund when i started realizing
some of these
you know issues percolating and really
starting to bother me
what really changed was two things
specifically so one is the jobs act
so when the jobs act allowed general
solicitation it actually changed the
landscape of how you could market to
people and how you could get people to
invest in your vehicle
the second thing which was equally
important was the maturation of
technology
so if you had the jobs act and you had
no way to identify find people market to
people create a seamless
investment process it wouldn't do much
for you it just meant that you could
host a party at your local golf club and
get people to show up and give them
you know free bagels and locks and see
if they want to invest
but with technology running at a pace of
growth
and efficiency as it was and i think
there was a huge change between like
2008 and 2015 and sort of what your
capabilities were and how you you know
distribute and consume information as
consumers
and how you sort of link to bank
accounts and just make the overall
process seamless
and what was really sort of the light
bulb went off is if you remember in like
2013-14 when lending club and prosper
really started to take off
so the notion of being able to originate
investments credit and distribute it in
mass seamlessly was like a big aha
moment where it was like wait
you can leverage technology marketing
and this new regulatory environment
to leverage the masses to create
financial equality like i think we could
actually do it now
uh one huge problem i had the investment
side
and i had the strategic you know
foresight i did not have
the technology the marketing and the
operation skill set and so um
i'm all sort of hot and bothered by this
idea about this mission
and i get introduced to melinda my
co-founder
and melind which was super interesting
for me he came from the exact opposite
side
so malin grew up in india he and his
wife he came over here to boston for
college
uh that's really when he came to america
and melinda
um is an engineer by trade
and uh he was always incredibly
passionate about how do we
leverage technology to solve for sort of
the white space like big big problems
and for him he was you know part of the
early 2000's glory
and uh you know god knows what his uh
his paper net worth was at the time
and he saw it all vanish and he also
appreciated again in 2008 that he was
putting his 401k
in all his savings and he saw this huge
decline now fortunately for milan
he didn't pull out because he was still
a high earner he was still you know in a
good business growing his career
young etc and so he saw the capability
of being able to be part of that
convexity
but when he sold yodel to web.com for
just under
350. he had another major financial
event and he was like okay how am i
going to
set my family up properly and he's going
around looking for investment
opportunities and he hits the same wall
that all the other people we mentioned
it right
high minimums long lockups not really
being
welcomed or able to participate in this
world of passive income specialty
finance
and so he became super passionate about
creating financial equality and a path
to
financial independence leveraging
technology and so when we meet it's like
you know love at first sight
it's a super synergistic um skill sets
expertise passion like think about the
greatest companies right it's about
building
and solving for problems that you have
yourself for your loved ones and for
your friends
and so that's how we got on this journey
to yield street our mission right now
is by 2025 we want to have 5 million
customers
we want to distribute 20 billion of
investments
and help people generate 3 billion of
income that they otherwise would not
have access to outside of the public
markets
and uh and that's that's a bit about our
founding story
and talk a little bit about kind of this
focus on alternative assets
um how do you see that in
investors portfolios today how has that
changed over the last couple of months
as we've kind of seen this
chaos in uh in the legacy financial
system
uh the the fed's stepping in and
lowering rates and printing money and
kind of
all the the nonsense that's been going
on how do you kind of just see
the alternative investment bucket
um either growing shrinking staying the
same in people's uh
portfolios very loaded question
um intentionally yes okay
so i mean high level
retail is always lagging the
institutional world
right the institutional world and that's
fairly simple and it makes sense
institutional world is filled with
people who are highly compensated to
identify better investment strategies
okay so you know you and i sitting at
home or even talking to people
being sophisticated we don't have a
horsepower that you know a black rock or
someone else has
and so what you'll see in every trend
and you know even when basic portfolio
theory was started right and every trend
retail is always going to be lagging
so if you go back even 10 years ago we
started institutions started moving 10
into alts now i think what you're seeing
is as a result of interest rates being
low so it's all the volatility in the
market
if you think about if you're an
endowment and you have a five percent
annual threshold that you have to meet
for your obligations for your charitable
givings etc
you can't get that with treasuries you
can't get that in bond market so you
gotta look elsewhere and so
you're seeing a massive shift we're
seeing 20 30 of people's portfolios
moving into alternatives
i think it's still going to take a
little bit more time for retail to get
there
but the bigger issue for retail was a
couple of things
hey how do i get access to it right do i
want to go on to like uh bkln and make
four percent like where's all that xsp
you're seeing all these hedge fund
managers and all these big asset
managers making so much money why aren't
we seeing the same thing
when we invest in their strategies it's
because by the time we get there it's
fees and fees
and fees and fees and fees and so the
access part
is a big issue to actually helping
people access small alternatives
if they were conscious of wanting to get
there even sooner
the second thing is i think
that what people's desires
of investing in the past might be
different today than they were
if you think back 30 40 years ago you
were a career employee
you went to a particular company you
worked there your whole life
you retired you got a pension you put
your money away and then you started
collecting income
the way we work today is changing right
so people work five years seven years
they take a break for a year they want
to
people spend more money on experiences
people build bigger
homes get nicer cars like growing up you
shared a room with your brother
it's not as common these days right and
so if you just think about the way
we live our lives and the goals that
people have
it also requires them to think
differently about how they invest
do i want to have passive income do i
want to make my money work for me
you want to get a car you want to go on
a vacation you want to build a house
whatever it is you want to do
how do i spend profit and not principal
and so being a part of the alternative
space
gives you a lot of advantages and
alternatives is a big word so we're
focused mostly on credit or special
situations
right and so it's going to in our case
we're going to look for assets that are
lower correlation to the markets we're
going to look for opportunities to
generate consistent passive income
we're going to look for opportunities
that have downside protection
we prefer to have less volatility i
think that
investors generally like sure it's
amazing if you look at the last couple
days in the market
that you know we've shot up like crazy
look at last week
we tanked like raising emotionally i
don't think we want to keep going
through these gyrations
and so the the reality is that
investors i believe have stuck to stocks
and bonds
mostly because of the limitation of what
they were being offered
and the experience in which they can
access them you don't want to go and get
a 100 page ppm
and sign the entire pvm when you can't
understand anything you want to come to
a platform that's digitally native
that speaks to you today you want to see
things in infographics you want to see
things in webinars you want things to be
broken down to you you want to consume
information
we have a policy here at yield street if
you can't explain the deal to your
mother we shouldn't do it
period end the story when someone comes
in and says i have the most complex
structure in the world but you're going
to make all the money in the world it's
like thanks but no thanks we're not
smart enough
that's it and so i think that
as people think about their financial
goals
how they want to grow their assets do
they want to achieve financial
independence
how do we get there alternatives is
speaking more and more and more
to what your goals what your desires are
if you look back
at data that talks about when people
have access to alternatives so we have
this great slide that we use all the
time
um here at yield street to show an
investor journey's life
okay so look at it from 18 to 80. so in
the early part of live called 18 20 25
it's all debt student debt housing debt
auto debt credit cards and the list goes
on
as you start growing up you get a job
and now you have a 401k
then you have a little stocks and bonds
etc etc we only saw
10 of people being able to invest at the
age of 65 or above
in alternatives why because the minimums
were high the lockups were long
they didn't have the financial
wherewithal to get into those
products at yield street leveraging
technology
we were able to bring that back our
average user is 42.
so you know the power of compounding 23
years of investing
23 more years what is that you know how
far can that get you that's how we help
people
achieve that goal and so when you think
about the broader backdrop of what's
happening with interest rates
you think about the volatility you think
about the reality that people
aren't actually getting ahead
you think about how many companies were
public 10 years ago versus how many
companies are public today with the
advent
and the growth of the private equity in
the venture markets we're not actually
accessing the level scale or quality of
companies
that we were 20 years ago or even 10
years
so when you invested in an apple early
on or in one of these
other major companies whether it's
microsoft or exxon or who knows what it
was
you were able to participate in that
convexity and that growth of equity and
that growth of the business today
companies are staying private much much
longer and maybe never even seeing the
light of the public forum
and so you don't really have that
convexity story
other than high-risk high-reward
businesses like in the tech space and
otherwise so where are you going to find
an attractive
yield or asset appreciation model
with limited limited risk with downside
protection with collateral with loans
etc
and so that's why that's why
institutions are moving there and that's
why retail is moving there more and more
aggressively
and so to answer you know one of your
questions where do i think it's going i
think we're going to see 30 to 40
percent of people's overall portfolio
and alts over the next five years
how much of the obstacle right now is
regulation right we recently saw a
little bit more in uh
some of the uh crowdfunding regulation
um kind of go from a million dollars to
5 million and there's a little bit of
progress happening there
but we still live in this society that's
driven by
regulators where they essentially one
use net worth as a
uh signal for intelligence right or kind
of a proxy for intelligence
uh two there's maybe some you know uh
lack of insolvency if you've got
somebody who's rich and they make a
small investment that you know they're
not gonna
miss the rent payment because of it um
but but there's a ton
of um kind of regulatory tape and
obstacles
that prevent the average person who you
know
makes 50 60 000 a year they go to work
every day they do a great job
they don't have millions of dollars to
invest how do we kind of
get them into some of these uh
investment opportunities in the private
market or in the alternative space that
um
you know either one have been difficult
to access right sounds like you guys are
solving that with technology but two
there's still this kind of regulatory
obstacle as well it's a great question
um for me it's a mixed bag is the truth
and i think people don't people don't
look at it this way enough in my
personal opinion
so first of all i think an honor about
december 8th
the accredited investor definition is
changing to be more inclusive
okay so it's going to include qualified
employees
it's going to include sort of a larger
subset of people is it where it should
be in my opinion
no is it a step in the right direction
absolutely
i think that
the challenge for the regulators is you
got to look at it this way
from their perspective right let's start
from their perspective and then i'll
share my perspective
from their perspective their job is to
protect the us consumer
to the best of their ability
what they see is a world of private
investments
that has
limited transparency in some respects
and at the end of the day sure could
they make it available to everyone yeah
are people going to get hurt in that
process but unscrupulous businesses
yes who's the first person they're going
to blame the regulators
and so if you think about the the risk
reward
for the regulatory bodies it's really
not in their favor at all
i don't think that's an excuse though
right i think that
we all have sort of risk in our roles
and i think their job is to is to find
the right balance to protect the
american consumer but to give them an
opportunity to get ahead and grow and
to see economic freedom um and i think
you're trying to do it
right and there and i think a great
example is
what they're doing on on digital banking
trying to create sort of a licensing
model for digital banks
lightening the requirement for a credit
investor
allowing reg a plus certain things have
happened
even the general solicitation concept is
a huge huge move i mean i could never
call you out of the blue and say anthony
you want to invest in this product
and so we are moving in the right
direction
this uh current administration has been
very
pro the relaxing of some of these
regulations
some of the bigger challenges just
practical challenges i would say are a
few things
one is they're always on the back nine
meaning we as entrepreneurs as business
owners as fund managers as people
you know engulfed in the financial
sectors are the ones creating
and manufacturing new products and new
structures all the time they need to
catch up with
us and they want to see what goes wrong
and what goes right during that process
and i think the world we live in today
moves so much quicker than it did in the
past
it's just difficult for them to be able
to sort of run checks and balances to a
certain extent
and so i think functionally it's
difficult
i think a solution to that is how do we
have more of a partnership with the
regulators right
part of the problem is that the people
who have an outnumbered seat at the
table are the incumbents
the incumbents aren't particularly
interested in helping the small guy
it doesn't serve their business model
well technology is a disrupter so for
yield street
you want to put in 5 000 great you want
to put in 5 million fantastic
doesn't change anything it's the same
clicks of the buttons and so we have
investors all across
sort of the the investment total
investment size
from literally as small as 5 000 to as
high as tens of millions
and so i think that's a challenge for
them and i think the solution again is
how do we figure out and create a better
partnership you know a think tank model
hey this is what we're building this is
why we're building it let's work
together
the second thing is that as much as we
want to sort of deregulate
it's not the easiest process it's not
like oh yeah you know this makes sense
these guys are really trying to help
other people we should let that happen
like okay we're just going to cut the
1940x just you know
that's fine or the 1933 that seems like
a little you know
a little outdated let's let's cut it up
and so the process and the bureaucracy
that exists
to move some of these things along
unfortunately is very real
and it takes some time i think we're
going in the right direction
i think that's the most important thing
i can tell you from our personal
experience so yield street is a
regulated entity
we go through ordinary examinations as
any other registered investment advisor
would
and i will tell you that the level of
engagement especially on our first
exam a couple years ago was much much
higher than i thought it would be
and i think that obviously they were
doing their job and doing the proper
sort of examination and going through
and learning
but i think there was a tremendous
amount of education that was happening
on their part and saying like hey if you
think back in 2016 when we started
nobody was doing this and like the
notion that you could distribute 10
million
dollars in hours or minutes is a crazy
thought and it was never been done
before
and so making sure that the right checks
are in place do you really do kyc how do
you think about accredited investor
verification is your technology
supporting these things and just going
through all that
there is going to naturally be an
education cycle
but again i think in summary we are
headed in the right direction
we have seen improvements continuously
over the years
can we do better sure but everyone can
do better business owners regulators
government so that's not
you know that's not uh that's not
something to knock on
i think what we really have to think
about broadly from a macro perspective
is where are we giving people access and
where are we not
and is the logic supportive so should
people
have more capability to invest in pink
sheets
and biotechs or secure private credit
i would argue that secure private credit
is a thousand times safer than pensions
and so i think we have to be a little
bit more logical
about how we think about why we want to
give access
to different cohorts of investors but
also how do we protect them
i do think that if you're if you're
looking squarely
at the logic behind the sec it's not to
suggest that wealthier people
are smarter it's to suggest that
wealthier people
have potentially more bandwidth
for error the margin of error is
is less impactful so if somebody is sort
of at the the cutting edge of a forty
thousand dollar annual job
and they scrape ten thousand dollars
together and they invest in a deal the
deal goes sideways
that's gonna be a really bad event for
that person if somebody has a hundred
thousand or two hundred thousand
investable cash the ten thousand dollar
deal goes sideways
that's a bad event but it's much less
impactful
and so from that perspective alone
they're trying to to protect people
i do think people have the right to say
hey you know
i should be the deciding factor of what
my risk barometer
is and i think that is the the challenge
that they're dealing with and thinking
about how to open regulation up
do we have hurdles in what we can offer
to people because of regulation sure
how do we deal with it really have to
find
structures that are old
but together with our technology we can
come up with a solution
so to be specific we launched the 40 act
fund in march of this year
which is available to non-accredited
investors as well does give them access
to a portfolio of investments that are
inherently diversified by multiple
positions and is an investment minimum
of five thousand dollars
so you can do it it took us 18 months it
costs a fortune which i'm never going to
publicly say
it was a grueling process and i think
that you know i think that's a bigger
issue like the moats to entering into
creating these things are just super
super high if you're not super well
funded and have an amazing team and
have access to some of the best legal
staff etc you can't get that off the
ground and i think that's
a cycling innovation question which is a
different story
but you can't fix it all in one day but
i think as long as we're going in the
right direction
and we're not regressing then you know
we should be we should be celebrating
the progress absolutely you guys have
done a great job kind of navigating this
environment
what are some of the more uh popular or
interesting
either opportunities or mechanisms on
the yield street platform and
obviously understand that there's a
bunch of regulation as to
you're not trying to promote them but if
used without name um
you can kind of describe the types of
things that people are coming to yield
street to get exposure to
yeah i think that what's most
interesting about yield street
any other platform that's out there is
like as i think about what are our key
differentiators right what are the real
modes in the business and how are we
different
and so when you talk to
other sort of fintech businesses there's
a few things that i think come to mind
so one is i think fintech is a term
that's abused
um every day what fintech is supposed to
mean
is a balance between financial services
and technology
that help a business become much more
destructive
when you look at most companies they're
either started by a finance professional
who hires a cto which usually ends up
with
limited technology a beautiful website
some functionality and a bunch of people
in back office doing the same thing you
were doing if you were in a
tech business when you have a tech ceo
who hires a finance professional what
you have is
super robust tech you have ai you have
you know
incredible apis you have beautiful user
experiences you have all this other
stuff
but there generally isn't the right
amount of rigor on asset performance and
asset quality
and i think what we have to do and i
know that we talk about it every day one
of our core values at yieldstreet is
investor first
you got to know a couple things one is i
don't care how wealthier you are or not
the money that you're putting on your
street or any other platform is harder
than money
number two is not everything's always
going to go right okay and so you got to
have a tremendous attention to detail
and focus on asset quality and asset
performance i always say never invest
with someone because they can make you
money
right we used to have this line and my
office used to be on the 54th floor
and um you know everybody comes in
pitching the flavor of the month of
their
their idea and i would always say you
can take a million dollars in cash
open up the window shake it out express
elevator downstairs we'll get down there
we'll be a dollar left
putting money out is the easy part
bringing it back home is where is where
the talent is
and so i think there's got to be real
attention to detail and asset quality
and so the first thing that i think
about when you look at the leadership at
yield street
is you have melind who is purely your
tech entrepreneur and all things we
discussed before
who has sort of this real from a
leadership perspective real pressure
real focus on the team
how do we leverage data technology to
create a solution to this bigger problem
right and from my perspective is how do
we focus on asset quality to make sure
that we're always distributing
best in class opportunities full well
knowing that not everything's going to
go perfect but we've got to have the
team that understands how to deal with
those situations
and so you have a team that really has
serious rigor in both financial services
and technologies i think that's key
differentiator number one
number two is when you talk to a lot of
these different businesses
you know they want to distribute real
estate they want to
so they'll say we're democratizing
fractional ownership or democratizing
access to real estate or some other
asset class etc
and i think when we talk about it at
yield street it's a much bigger picture
so i told you what our mission was right
if you think about it practically
the how is to create a digitally native
solution that really is a one-stop shop
for wealth management and wealth
creation in a curated fashion so you've
got tv ameritrade that's got every
option in the world
i'm going to ask you anthony what do i
know what are your favorite
opportunities on td ameritrade it's like
call me back in a month when i figure
out the 17 000 options they're offering
right
and so i think consumers today want
duration so you look across the risk
reward spectrum i want some
you know bonds here i want cash and cash
alternatives
i want uh equity i want debt i want um
high growth equity like venture capital
some higher some higher reward et cetera
but i want to curate it so based on my
preferences my income my expenses etc
show me the three or four best options
for me
so i'll give you an example you look out
right now on you know
in sort of the wall street world you
have every top name manager
raising capital for what they're calling
distress funds or copic dislocation
funds okay so think about
the aviation industry at its peak during
cove
dropped 92 in activity so if i ask you
do you think in
x number of years from now whether it's
six months or two years are people still
going to be traveling
are people going to be traveling more
than they did last year right like
that's part of who we are today we
travel we're global citizens okay and so
there's going to be a shift in ownership
a shift in the capital structure of
maybe who owns the planes or how they're
owned or
someone hasn't paid their bills in nine
months so they're in default right so
there's a lot of distress opportunities
you think about hotels
you walk around new york city most of
the hotels are closed the ones that are
open barely have any services
and so there's going to be distress in
the market and people and these funds
are sort of going out there and raising
enormous amounts of money
to take advantage of that you know
seeking to generate returns of 12 15 20
over the next few years i don't know
anyone in retail who's gonna get access
to that but they should
right and so when we think about
what we're providing to you and why
we're differentiated it's how do we
create a solution for you
across your whole portfolio so we want
to be that place
that brings you a great experience
that's digitally native that has your
app it has your web portal
that's exactly how you if you close your
eyes and you envisioned
how do i interact with the money this is
what it would be
and for us there's a much bigger
thinking behind it right
and the question is from a social
behavior perspective
what has changed over the last number of
years and where are we going
and how do we be part of that story or
lead that story
and so i have two great examples if
you'll indulge me
first one is 15 20 years ago what was
your favorite cell phone
15 years ago it's probably uh what they
have like the sidekick
the razor all those right maybe i even
have it
i know so i usually have like a v phone
and a nokia on my desk
yeah somebody's gonna take him and so i
would i would go for the nokia or the
razer right the smaller you can get as
long as i could play snake
for my emails i had my blackberry a
couple years later but it took me like
god knows how long to separate from the
two-phone model and go to my iphone
let me ask you this when we got our
nokias we were looking for the smallest
phone as we possible
and we didn't want to spend more than
like 200 250. i remember when that razor
came out it was 450 bucks like people
were having a heart attack
okay so now you're spending two three
four five times the money on the phone
it's four or five times the size it's
got way more glitches than my nokia ever
had
my battery on my key lasted a week long
and i think i played more snake than
anyone i know on the blackberry
brick breaker but here i am buying an
iphone for a thousand bucks 1200 bucks
what happened let's talk about the way
we shop
i remember i used to help my mom do
errands and go to the baker the butcher
the fisherman the flower store the
variety store
the bank now i walk into whole foods
where you walk into
your local equivalent your one-stop shop
bro
so we're fundamentally changed the way
we behave and interact with different
things in our life
i think if you if you break down the
behavior we were
task-based seekers so we were looking
for maximum efficiency
at a task level i want the best phone i
want the best messaging i want the best
fish etc
to being utility seekers i want to do
the most i can
with the least effort is everything
going to be as good as if it was if i
was singular focused
no am i okay with it yeah is technology
going to get better over time is the
store going to have better quality over
time yeah
but i'm coming here for now now let's
think about your financial life how many
bank accounts do you have
how many credit cards you have how many
different investments you have
how many 401 k's if you're in your 40s
and so
everything else in our life is getting
more efficient focus more on utility
but the part that's like arguably most
important maybe healthcare
is similar right and same issues there
the part that's most important that we
interact with every day how we spend
money how we make money
every single day you don't move without
getting a coffee without doing this
without doing that
is completely fragmented that makes no
sense to us at yieldstream
and the question is how do we solve that
issue how do we create
one digitally native platform where you
can have an enjoyable experience but
specifically that is designed for you
and delivers to you the curated
solutions of what you're looking for
and over time what you'll see at yield
street over the next number of years is
how do we continue to introduce more and
more investment product
and other products whether it's advice
or tax etc
to really create this ecosystem around
anthony's financial world that he feels
comfortable
in this one spot and nobody else is
thinking about it like that
not a single platform and when you think
through that
um there's kind of two parallel trends
here right one is kind of this like land
and expand strategy
with a user or a consumer so if i can
get you to start buying
secured credit now all of a sudden i can
offer you
parallel products i can offer you advice
around those products i can kind of wrap
services around it i can
really create that ecosystem you just
described but at the same time there's
also this like
uh financialization of everything right
if you look at
a company that like uh maybe a pipe who
is literally going out and creating a
financial product out of sas revenue
uh contracts or you kind of go through
all these different assets that are now
uh becoming investible in some form or
fashion uh you even see this in like
sports cards and kind of all this crazy
stuff that's going on
it feels like that is a second tailwind
that is happening in finance is that
something where
you guys will also start to get into the
more kind of esoteric alternatives as
well and you think that's interesting
or is it something where you want to
stay kind of down the fairway from a
investable asset standpoint and then
just kind of build out that ecosystem
around those
kind of more straightforward investment
opportunities
i think a couple interesting points to
pick up from there
so one is
i think in part because of where rates
are
and people seeking yield and seeking
higher returns
people are trying to get more creative
that's number one
number two i think that people are using
passion in different ways to direct
their investments
i think that's much more sort of a
younger generation millennial
practice than maybe our parents so
whether it's a focus on esg or focus on
collectibles it's hey
i want to make my money doing something
that aligns with who i am
right or what i'm interested in um
i think the other side is in like for
example you touched on collectibles
the whole collectible industry has blown
up in an amazing way
part of it is because digitalization
part of this is globalization
part is because there's far more
millionaires today than there ever were
before
right so entrepreneurs businesses all
that people spend money in different
places
you think about like the watch industry
is insane you think and like that's like
a real
you know commoditized asset at this
point liquid market
you think about art um i think the other
side is
people recognizing that an asset should
be considered an asset irrespective of
what the underlying asset is like i'll
give you something that's like less
known
for example was it almost 30 years ago
at this point maybe 20 some odd years
ago
if you remember the tobacco companies
had the largest settlement in history
when they settled those big tobacco
cases a lot of the payments
were structured to the law firms and
trust
over a 20 or 30 year period i don't
remember exactly where it was
so imagine you're a lawyer you worked on
a case you get this big fee now you got
to get paid over the next 20 years
so what people did was they went out and
sold the payment stream either in the
securitization market
or through private investors so we had
one on the platform a couple years back
and so here you had a payment instrument
guaranteed by
philip morris let's say who his public
debt was trading at nothing
but you were able to get you know a nine
percent or an eight percent yield
on the payment strength and so i think
what people are looking at today
is saying if i own a piece of art and
the art market has a significant amount
of data now
and the particular artist you can have a
good understanding
you know call it real blue chips like a
dead artist 100 years ago
5 million plus art and so there's a
there is a way to create a thesis around
where that art should trade over a
period of time
and where rates are today and where
people looking for
better stores and value and better tax
strategies there is a theory of why it
would make sense to go there
so i think like that's part of the
reason why you're seeing some of that
i obviously disagree with a lot of the
stuff that people are creating sort of
investable assets just
you know jumping on the bandwagon sort
of uh you know high tide photo you know
rise slow boost kind of thing
for yield street specifically our goal
was never to be
like the the innovator of investment
strategies
like i leave that to the best hedge
funds in the world and the best asset
manager in the world
our entire idea was how do we leverage
technology to create what i call
distribution infrastructure
so we got hundreds of thousands of
people we have this amazing user
experience and technology where we can
distribute fantastic shouldn't say
fantastic we could distribute product
that could be interesting to a bunch of
people
on the other side you can use that same
technology on the consumer side as how
do i create
for myself the best wealth management
solution
in my personal opinion it's not by
trying to reinvent the wheel and say hey
i think um ring lights are going to be
like the the craziest thing
because everyone's home now in covet and
they want to look better on uh
on an interview so i'm going to invest
in the green the you know
the ring light manufacturer i think that
for me it's too much risk i think if you
look around the investment world
there's trillions of dollars of
investable product with track records of
proven managers etc
within that universe you can access the
entire risk profile
you want to look for something that goes
like that let's go find a good early or
late stage vc
and participate in their fund you want
to find something that's super tax
efficient and you live in new york
let's find the best new york bonds and
curate them to you and so i don't
foresee in the near future like yield
street selling bitcoin investments or
you know some other much more
speculative opportunity sets
when you think about kind of where you
guys are going let's say
20 years from now 10 years from now
what's the kind of one or two sentence
here's what the goal is here's what the
mission is
uh and where you want to be
i think in 10 years from now honestly i
want to get there sooner but let's say
in 10 years from now
i want you street to be the household
name globally
for digital wealth management across the
board
it's a pretty uh that's a pretty good
goal to have before
i think it's really doable like i think
you know who is that name today
doesn't exist i think the incumbents
it's too difficult for them to build
what we're building right we're starting
on you know
2015 to 2017 technology and iterating
you know daily on it they're 20 30 years
behind
massive infrastructures it just
it just can't be done yeah so i think
honestly i think we have a real shot at
it i think we have a massive head start
there is like if i asked you like hey
who do you think is like our number one
direct competitor
there isn't a clear answer and i think
when you when you really think about
yield street it's a category creator
and as long as we continue to scale and
to grow and to build
thoughtfully meant in a measured way and
by being investor first and delivering
what people really
need to help fuel their financial
ambitions and i think that's going to be
us in 10 years
i love that answer uh before i wrap up i
always ask people the same two questions
and you'll get to ask me one question at
the end
the first question is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
this is a tough one this is a really
tough one
you can answer with two or three if you
can't decide between the absolute best
i my biggest problem with books is that
i think most of them should be shorter
and um i think there are a few key
takeaways
in different books and um
i i don't know that there's a particular
book that i think is like the all-time
best book
ever read because i read across many
different genres um
for me i'll tell you some some of the
more recent ones
the book called before um
that i found really interesting it
essentially analyzes
facebook um
amazon apple and
um
maybe uber i believe
anyway it looks at the it looks deeply
into the companies
to understand what is it what is really
so special
about those businesses that allowed them
to ignore the success that they had
and it gives you a very different
perspective in understanding some of
that strategy
but what it also focuses on in the book
is how do you
as a student which i thought was really
interesting
how do you as a student think about
these concepts
in the book and i'll mention one in a
second and
help that thinking apply sort of where
you want to go next
and try to identify the whole notion of
the book is who's going to be the fifth
horseman right so let's look at
all the components that make these
companies so special and go
from there so like one interesting
example to me that sort of
you know blew my mind for a moment was
when you think about apple
so um is apple a technology company or
consumer brand
and so the author asks
when apple unveiled the apple watch they
did an 18-page spread
in a particular magazine what would be
like the first magazine that came to
mind for you
well because you're asking now i think
it's like vogue but if you hadn't told
me that it would have been some kind of
technology magazine
you know tech bonds or whatever yeah
there was an 18 page spread in vogue
with an 18
000 for a mez band right and so we go
into the psychology behind
the glass storefront so the whole glass
storefront
is really about you walking outside
seeing the person inside and aspiring to
be able to buy that thousand dollar
phone
and the person inside being able to feel
like hey look at me i'm buying this
phone
and so it's a completely different way
of thinking about how to build that
brand how they thought about that
company
the notion of leveraging technology is
to bring costs down
so here you have the most expensive
device when it's supposed to be a tech
company first right
so there's a lot interesting things
there i thought that was a really
interesting book
[Music]
another book for me is
it's called um the road to
[Music]
you're really getting me here i'm just
impressed with myself that i knew the
name of a magazine outside of the tech
world
yeah i mean i i felt like all your
subscribers know that your go-to vogue
but that's okay um
the other question i asked everyone was
the character who wrote a character
what is that incredible book so the road
to character
goes through you know people throughout
history
great people throughout history and
really
focuses on how they got to greatness how
they achieved what they achieved
and the common theme across the board is
number one having real major setbacks
whether like real travesty or real
challenges
and having this incredible burning sort
of desire for their mission their vision
their purpose and resilience
and as you sort of go through the book
time and time and time again
it sort of makes you it forces you to
recognize which i think a lot of people
internally know but we don't talk about
it as much
about how that road to character and
maintaining a moral high ground and
being able to see these visions through
is always met with enormous amounts of
obstacles and it's about getting past
them
right and so for me um
we're always going to have ups and downs
and you know what you see
or in the outside world from a company
like will street or others is you see uh
you know 14th
fastest growing company but then 46 the
next year which is like crazy your top
50 growing companies in america in two
years in a row
where you see like you know top of the
stack at financial times or cranes 40
under four you see all these great
apples
what you don't see is every setback
all the [ __ ] that you have to go through
pardon me but all the things that don't
work out well
right and so being in a startup
and being successful means you have to
have this incredible amount of luck
you got to have this amazing team
everything's got to go right you got to
find the product working fit and you're
still going to have a ton of things to
deal with
i think that that was really important
um and then
for me and maybe maybe the all-time
sort of best recurring read is not
actually a book or
by now is a book but it's the
compilation of warren buffett's essays
and the reason isn't because i think you
could glean the best investment advice
i think it's because who the man is
and when you bring it all together
whether it's humility
desire to have a better world whether
it's bringing calm to a chaotic
investment world
you start to take all those lessons and
you put them together and you see them
consistently evolve
over all the years i think as both a
business person
entrepreneur i look at myself and i try
to look at you know
the people on our team we have a term
here at eel street called the growth
seeker
we got to be looking to grow both
personally and professionally always
and so i think that if you look at his
journey
he represents that in a big way
personally i think if you look at most
billionaires
in the world there's always you know
some serious skeletons in the closet of
how they got there and you could just
you know
pull out forbes 400 and look right on
that list and you'll say okay
he stole that he did that he did that um
you don't really find that with him and
i think the one thing that's really
that can really stick home to everyone
is
the notion that behave today as if
tomorrow morning
everything you did today was on the
front page of wall street journal
and i think what's interesting about
that message is it's not telling you to
be a saint it's not telling you to be
perfect
but it's telling you that however you're
going to live and whatever you're going
to behave whether it's personally or
professionally
be okay with it being on the front page
maybe you'll be a little bit embarrassed
okay no one's perfect but don't do
something don't behave in a certain way
that that would be sort of
below the line for you and so i think
there's a lot of lessons
that come from him but i can go on those
are great those are great suggestions
the second question is more fun aliens
are you a believer
or non-believer
how do you define aliens do i believe in
life
outside of earth however you wanted to
define it everyone defines it
differently
so i would define that question as do
you believe
there is some form of life whatever that
means
um outside of planet earth and i would
say absolutely
why because i believe that things have a
purpose
and so we are you know
nothing relative to the broader galaxy
sort of the universe as a whole
we like to human beings like to think of
life in terms of earth
and earth is nothing comparatively to
the bigger universe and so the simple
question is
uh if not for life or for some purpose
what is it
and so i don't know the answer so that's
not go there
but i do believe there's something
whether they're gonna come and like
destroy us like that's not a high
it doesn't rank high on sort of my
anxiety at all or i focused
we want to find them for sure we don't
want them finding us
yeah i don't know again like i don't
know about that
we've managed to live this many years
here and like nobody's
coming and destroying us tomorrow
morning i mean uh if they're if that
happens
thank god well smith is still around
exactly i am legend will come save us
but um
i don't we'll leave that up to others
to finish up you could ask me one
question what's the one question you
have for me
how has your um how's your military
background
helped you in your career in building
what you built here
and can you leverage that to help others
who have similar military background be
as successful as you've been
and how do the rest of us do more of
that
yeah i think there's probably two things
and you know one of them is like a
pretty uh dark view of the world of just
like we're all gonna die
right so uh when you kind of are
immersed for
a prolonged period of time in uh you
know combat scenario
where there's kind of always injuries
and death and
that's always kind of part of the
conversation and just around you for
you know even it was just a couple of
weeks if not you know
a year plus um i think that you just
generally
uh get this understanding of like hey we
are all
going to die and so like live life to
the fullest while you're here
uh when i was younger you know i came
back from iraq when i was i think 21
years old
and like as a 21 year old live life to
the fullest means you like go by a
motorcycle and you
fly down the highway at like 110 miles
an hour and
yeah and you feel invincible right as
you get older you rise like maybe that's
not the way to uh
uh to embody some of that but uh i i
definitely think that's one piece of it
and the second is just
um you know people always talk about
like the leadership
training uh of the military of the army
specifically
i was fortunate enough to go through a
bunch of their uh various schools
but i always tell folks that like the
best leadership lessons were not
learned at one of the leadership schools
that was more of just a formalization
yeah it was just the formalization of
what they wanted you to know right it
was out of a book it was in a
training scenario whatever the mba
graduate can go around a fortune 500
company day two
of course and so i think that it's you
know when you actually kind of go
through things in the tough situations
and stuff
like that that's really where a lot of
that kind of gets forged
and you know it's um it's cliche at this
point because so many of these
kind of great warriors that we have have
come back and leveraged social media to
kind of
build large audiences and stuff but you
know if you listen to like a jackal will
nick or david goggins or
uh tim kennedy or any of these guys like
they all pretty much have the same
message
right which is like personal
responsibility and like go do hard [ __ ]
so that
everything in life becomes easier like
that's not really
that groundbreaking of uh advice it's
just that they say it over and over and
over again and they embody it and kind
of do all these things
but the reason why so many people flock
to those messages is like because it's
true
right if you you know if every single
day you're doing just
things that suck and are hard and
difficult and all stuff
all of a sudden the problems you thought
you had become much easier right and so
it's just kind of
how do you constantly condition yourself
to have a little bit more that mental
fortitude and stuff like that and it
helps in every part of life and i think
that's a
a big lesson that people eventually
learn at some point in their life but i
think taking the trauma out
of you know what you just said so
let's take the death out of it for a
minute
the ability to recognize that um
a we don't control our outcome every day
and that b
everyone's going to die at some point so
another way of saying it is like forced
introspection
there's something very peaceful about
that that's it
it puts things into incredible
perspective and
sort of your desire to have more clarity
more authentic living more authentic
experiences more authentic relationships
is just that much more enjoyable and i
think in a different way
just a pivot to like covet coven in some
ways had that experience of a lot of
people
right it's like we all had this rat race
i mean
speaking for myself super rat race right
building this business
21 hours a day working i sleep with my
phone in my ear right and sleep in the
office sleep in the city
all this stuff on planes more than i you
know i want to attest to being
um the upside is i never work today
i love it and i feel incredibly
rewarded to sort of be building what
we're building like getting random
linkedin or
dms from people like hey oh my god i'm
putting my kid to college because i'm on
an investment heel street
never met you never will meet you or
being on a plane coming back from
austria and wearing this heel street
vest and someone comes over me and says
like
how did you get that vest and i was like
oh whatever what do you want to say
because you never know which way it's
going to go
and they're like it's the best company
ever i'm like oh actually right
so you just you get caught up in it and
um
i so i got three kids at home and um
in the first 10 weeks i ran the math
cumulatively
over the last 11 years married i haven't
spent this much time with them as i had
in the first 10 weeks right
and i think that when you're starting to
get these emails and these texts and
these whatsapp groups with all these
people
that you know or that are second third
relationship passing away and you see
all the
horror stories of sort of loss of life
and sickness
there was sort of a for those who who
connected with themselves and sort of
you know took a moment in time it's like
okay we've got to rethink some of this
stuff right like what's important in
life where are the relationships
you didn't see your friends for an
extended period of time or the people
you thought were your friends
and then you slowly started seeing
people that
you were particularly close with family
and friends and sort of
you spend more time with those people so
more intentional relationships right
more intentional meaning in life
spending more time
every day thinking about how to
crystallize what's important to you
and so i think that um the trauma is
something i can't speak to i just don't
you know thankfully don't have that
experience we don't know about that
but i think the upside is
you know if harnessed well is a
beautiful gift to have
to sort of be able to see things much
more clearly much more real
um and very early in life before it's
too late right
that is uh that is the way i view it at
least
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more
information about the company
the best place is yieldstreet.com um
so that's the best place you can come to
us on linkedin you can follow me on
linkedin
um but the website is super intuitive
it's enjoyable or download the old
street app
and um we're here for everybody ask us
any questions you have
and uh whatever we don't have that you
want
uh drop it in an email tell us because
we're here for you so we gotta build it
awesome man listen thank you so much for
doing this we're definitely gonna have
to do this again in the future
i look forward to it thank you have a
great day it was a great talk take care